when i told my mom i wanted to grow up
and be a comedian she said you can't do
both
and she's right being a comedian makes
you quite immature i'm sort of like a 14
year old boy trapped inside a man's body
not in a michael jackson way
because he's a child at heart not
because he [__] kids
because he definitely doesn't for legal
reasons so
good people of atlanta we must never
forget
that anthony bourdain
killed himself
anthony bourdain had the greatest job
that show business ever produced this
[__] flew around the world
and ate delicious meals with outstanding
people
that man with that job
hung himself in a luxury suite in france
they say 2 000
party over oops out of time
so tonight i'm gonna party like it's
1999.
i know a [__] in high school that was
an urban genius
this motherfucker's grades was so good
he got all the way from the hood to an
ivy league school with a full
scholarship
from there the [__] got himself
into one of the best law schools in the
country and when he was in law school
he met a woman
and they fell in love
and they were going to get married i
remember him telling me about it he was
home for christmas and i told him i said
my man my man
save that [__] for late in your life
[Applause]
but he's in love
he didn't listen to me he married her
while he was in law school and sadly
they got divorced while he was in law
school
he was a street [__] from the hood
this man had nothing
and that [__] took half of that
and then i just never saw him again for
years and then two years ago i was home
in dc doing some shopping trying to buy
my sons some socks and foot locker i go
to foot locker guess who's the manager
that [__]
dressed like a referee the whole [__]
this [__] is 45 years old
we went out drinking that night just
trying to catch up and
and he told me he said he's been living
with his mother for like 10 years just
trying to get back on his feet but
that's not the point of the story the
point of the story is
never occur to this [__] to kill
himself
he's alive and well in d.c
i even suggested to him that he should
try it out i don't know maybe
[Applause]
yo punjabis be honest when trudeau uh
did the punjabi face
and
what was more offensive that he put on
the turbine or he made y'all dark
skinned which was more offensive
[Applause]
yeah
there's a bunch of punjabis in the group
chat like yo how the [__] are you gonna
make a sri lankan bro this is crazy huh
we're from the north of india we're
fair-skinned
we lights light-skinned indians over
here get it right trudeau
you want this guy trudeau shut the [__]
up this guy
does anybody i mean does anybody like
him
let me like you right i know that's
funny scared of some truckers you saw
that [__] we'll have cobia i can't come
out here
you [__] [__] dude what a [__]
person
what a puzzle
his dad would be so embarrassed
because fidel castro was all about
protests and
i couldn't [__] stand that guy
he was so [__] negative he never
anything positive to say
hey steve what do you got for us today
in 2035 there'll be no more apples thank
you steve
thanks a lot
wasn't thinking about that now i am
hey so what's the solution it's too late
we needed to try 40 years ago thanks a
lot buddy i'm gonna go cry with my child
now
dude i can hang with that out with that
guy for about three minutes before i
took the break off his chair and just
zoomed him into the other room
hey steve come back and we've got
something dumb and positive to say no
one cares about movers anymore no one
goes to cinema no one really watches
network tv everyone's watching netflix
this show should just be me coming out
going well done netflix you win
everything good night but no no we gotta
drag it out for three hours you could
binge watch the entire first season of
afterlife instead of watching this show
that that's a show about a man who wants
to kill himself because his wife dies of
cancer and it's still more fun than this
okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end he obviously didn't
kill himself
just like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
as a young guy trying to achieve the
success that you have already achieved
you ain't that [__] young well
[__] with everybody that's a little
bit older well let's just wait a minute
nobody do don a legend so dirty like
that and me you know i'm 56 years old
damn
i'm sorry
are you all familiar with simon cowell
do you know simon cowell
simon cowell spends 500 000 pounds every
year on his own personal security that's
an extraordinary amount of money isn't
it half a million pounds a year on
personal security has simon not
considered being less of a [__]
i consider seth icon i do like i got a
critique about seth it's too much
seth
it's almost like he's jealous of his own
creation
where he wants to prove i'm better than
the cartoons see but i think the problem
is with seth is that he don't have a
partner you know like the the southpaw
guys or hannah barbera
i know we've read that old story that uh
hannah once said i'm bigger than yogi
and
barbara slapped the [__] out of him for
saying that
seth needs a barbera
[Laughter]
to slap him and slap him twice
once to say hey man don't forget why
people love you
and two
just say you're gay
no
no straight man writes that many show
tunes that's a fact
oh julia roberts you live next to me at
the beach you know that thanks for all
the visits
anyway
[Applause]
i'm living about two blocks from the
broad never shows up come by and say
hello
we're closer than two blocks i have no
lines julia just not
anyway
talking of the walking dead
congratulations to hugh hefner who uh is
getting married at the age of 84 to 24
year old beauty crystal harris um when
she was asked why she was marrying him
she said because he lied about his age
he told me he was 94. oh come on
um
don't worry
hold out and just just don't look at it
when you touch it
[Applause]
together again
[Music]
actually nerd jesus died in the last
year right
steve jobs
yeah he died right i know i know a lot
of nerds here tonight i know you're sad
i didn't get it i didn't get the big
deal they made about that guy
when he died they were like he changed
the world
that's insane
he changed the world
the world was one way
and then steve jobs came
and it was another
what did he do
somebody for the love of god what the
[__] did that guy do
what did he told other people what to
invent
i want my entire music collection in
that phone get on it
[Applause]
right
and then these poor nameless faceless
scientists got to go in the back room
and figure it out
how the [__] are we going to get all of
this
into this i mean
what year does this guy think this is
this is crazy this is like buck rogers
dude my kid has a birthday in like 11
months
steve jobs just walking by i don't hear
any thinking going on in there
just strutting around the office
eating some pretentious fruit like a
pear right
just throwing out ideas
or another one
there's another one i just came up with
on the way to work
i was reading a magazine the other day
turning pages you know i'd like to turn
pages on a screen that aren't even there
yeah wrap your [__] heads around that
guys
see you in eight years
where you going michael big little big
little get on it
right
then all these people slave away
to make his vision come true and then
they have the big nerd fest right
down there comic con and all their nerd
mecca they are all showing up with their
acne and their hulk sharks limping into
the arena right
does steve jobs go out with the whole
chorus line of scientists now he goes
out there by himself
sneakers are no belt like it was no
biggie right
like he's
like he's tesla
tapping into the atmosphere i know this
is always uncomfortable i know you
bought into it right
that whole advertising the way they
aligned themselves with some of the
greatest people of all time jesus gandhi
me
remember that muhammad ali john lennon
this guy
how the [__] was that dude like any of
them
gandhi didn't have a sweatshop
ah he didn't have people leaping to
their deaths only to get catch a net and
get ricocheted back through the window
to have to put together yet another ipad
john lennon didn't have children in his
basement pressing those
[__] albums
i know i know
new phone can't fit the old charger this
is your hero
this is the guy
this is what all the silence is about
new phone can't fit the old chargers and
then you got to throw it out ends up in
the ocean around some octopus's neck
do you realize how much sea life is
ecstatic that that man is no longer
walking the earth
[Applause]
that's where it all ends up you know
it doesn't go in a landfill ends up in
the ocean you realize that i hate people
who say i don't pollute i don't pollute
yeah you do you use [__] you throw it
out
what do you think cause you put in like
a basket it just poof disappears
everything he ever used is somewhere
even think about that
remember that flannel shirt you bought
back in the day when you got into pearl
jam
that's out there somewhere probably on
some porpoises face
trying to get it off
stupid little flippers
all the fads
you remember rollerblading
remember that everybody had them
we set up cones we did little tricks
right
one little homophobic joke killed that
entire fat
what's the hardest thing about
rollerblading telling your parents
you're gay
full-grown adults dude i'm not gay i
don't have the cooties these mean i suck
dick and they just threw them out
they end up in the ocean
they're made out of plastic they can't
bio-degrade they just break down the
little cubes fish are breathing them in
six months later you're going out you're
getting sushi you think you're being
healthy you're eating your old
rollerblades
all right i'm out of time you guys are
great thank you thank you thank you